MALE SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to another installment
of "Leading at Google." Today,
I'm proud to introduce Gautam
Mukunda, who is an assistant
professor at the Harvard
Business School.
He received his PhD from MIT in
political science and an AB
in government from Harvard.
Before graduate school, he was
a consultant at McKinsey,
where he focused on the
pharmaceutical sector.
His research focused on
leadership, international
relations, the social and
political implications of
technology change.
Today, he'll be talking about
his new book, "Indispensable,
When Leaders Really Matter,"
which you can get in the back
for a very Googly price.
Please welcome Gautam Mukunda.
GAUTAM MUKUNDA: Well,
good afternoon, I
guess, ladies and gentlemen.
It's a real pleasure
to be here.
So thank you very much
for inviting me.
I'm lucky I have one good
friend in the audience.
And I hope I'll have more by
the time this talk is over.
So as Alex told you, my name
is Gautam Mukunda.
The name of my book, which
just came out--
we have a problem with the mic?
No.
--just came out last month, is
"Indispensable, When Leaders
Really Matter." And so I always
like to start this talk
by asking people if there's
anyone on the roster up there
who they want to know who that
is, because what I discover is
that every audience gets
some of the people.
But so far, I've never had an
audience that gets all of the
people on this set.
Above Napoleon.
Ah, so that's Judah Folkman,
who's a cancer researcher, who
lived in Boston and died about
four years ago, who I'm
actually going to talk
about today.
He's actually one of my favorite
people in the talk--
really, really remarkable
human being.
One of the few people I've
profiled who I actually met
just before he died.
Anyone else?
Who are the two guys between
Welch and Churchill?
Between Churchill--
oh, and Jack Welch.
OK, so that's Jamie Dimon, who
is the CEO of JP Morgan Chase,
probably the most powerful man
in the financial world who
doesn't work for a government.
And that is Sir Jackie Fisher,
who was a British admiral who
completely revolutionized
naval warfare.
He, actually, is also profiled
in the book.
And Fisher is the most famous
admiral to have never fought
or won a battle.
And he has this sort of
incredible charisma that
historians fall in love with,
even though he actually never
commanded anything in battle.
Let's get started.
So my research in my book
is actually about a
pretty simple question.
And it's one that I'm pretty
confident that all of you have
thought about at least once,
probably in those classic dorm
room debating sessions.
And the question is
simply this--
do individuals make
a difference?
Is it possible for a single
individual, a leader, to be in
the right place at the right
time, where the fact that that
person was there changed
the course of history?
So it was that person and not
any of the other people who
logically could have
been in that place.
So when could someone
like that be in
a position of power?
Under what circumstances does
a person who makes a
difference, who changes history
for better or for
worse, gain power?
Very good and very
bad leaders.
So let me give you an example of
what I mean by just how big
individual impact
can really be.
This is probably the ultimate
example, I think, in modern
history of a single individual
changing
the course of history--
Napoleon Bonaparte.
Napoleon is given his first
major command in the French
military in 1796, because
he assures the French
revolutionary government that
he has no significant
political interests.
He wins a series of brilliant
victories in Italy, is
defeated in the Middle East,
returns to France, and
suddenly acquires political
interest, because he
overthrows the French
government.
And he becomes the undisputed
ruler of France, probably the
most powerful nation in the
world, at the age of 30.
In 1799, Napoleon strides France
and then Europe like a
colossus and plunges the
continent and, really, the
world, into 16 years
of warfare.
When we think about the Second
World War, we think about
Hitler, who's sort of the single
person probably most
responsible for causing it.
But we don't call the Second
World War Hitler's War.
We call this entire era of
16 years the era of the
Napoleonic Wars.
So in 1815, Napoleon has
been defeated once.
He's been exiled to the
island of Elba.
And then he returns.
And he lands in Southern
France.
And the general of the French
armies, who actually was one
of Napoleon's former
subordinates, promises that he
will capture Napoleon and
bring him back to
Paris in an iron cage.
So he goes down to the front
with his troops.
And they meet Napoleon.
And Napoleon walks up to the
soldiers-- one of the most
dramatic moments you can
imagine, right?--
and he puts his chest against
their bayonets.
And he says, "Soldiers of
France, I am here." And they
throw their weapons down and put
him up on their shoulders
and carry him in triumph back
to Paris, where he promptly
takes over the French government
once again.
And so then this news arrives
at the Congress of Vienna,
which was actually meeting in
the Netherlands at the time.
And the news arrives
at the Congress.
The Congress has met to
determine what Europe will
look like with the end of
the Napoleonic Wars.
So meeting in this conference
for the first time ever in the
same place is the head of the
British government, the czar
of Russia, the emperor
of Austria,
and the king of Prussia--
four of the five most powerful
people in the world all
meeting at the same time.
And when the news arrives that
Napoleon has retaken Europe,
the czar of Russia, the absolute
ruler of the largest
nation in the world, turns to
the Duke of Wellington, the
British soldier who's proven
himself to be the only
commander who can meet
Napoleonic generals on even
terms and win, and says to him,
"My Lord Duke, only you
can save Europe."
And then the Congress
declares war.
Austria, Prussia, Russia, and
Great Britain declare war, but
not on France.
They declare war on
Napoleon, by name.
Four countries versus
one person.
So this, to my mind, is
individual impact that's about
as large as it's possible
to imagine--
one person who completely
transforms the course of
European history.
But how does someone
like that happen?
What's the circumstances where
you get something like that?
So let me step you through
my answer.
I'm going to suggest to you a
theory that I call leader
filtration theory that explains
when individual
leaders who really make a
difference can take power.
I'm going to give you a
statistical test to validate
that theory, some historical
examples, and talk you through
how the same theory can apply
in business, in science, and
implications for your
own types of work.
So starting off with leader
filtration theory.
So the funny thing about leaders
is that practitioners
and social scientists have
completely different ideas
about them.
If you're in business, in
politics, in the military, if
you're a reporter, if you're a
historian, you universally
believe that you cannot
understand events unless you
understand the leaders who are
in charge of the organizations
that are doing those things.
But if you're a social
scientist, social scientists
almost uniformly argue that
leaders don't matter, that who
is in charge of an organization
actually has very
little importance.
And this is probably the single
largest gap between
academics who study
organizations
and everyone else.
So why?
Why do political scientists,
management theorists,
economists, why do they all
say leaders don't matter?
And they have three reasons.
And they're three very
powerful reasons.
The first one is this idea that
every organization has
external constraints.
You guys know this, although
maybe Google knows this less
well than almost any
other organization.
It's the idea that you cannot
do whatever you want freely,
because your competitors
will counteract you.
You can't set your prices at
whatever level you want,
because your competitors
will undercut you.
Internal constraints.
A leader can't do anything he
or she wants, even if the
external environment won't
stop them, because every
organization has politics,
every organization has
interests, every organization
has groups inside it that will
push back against certain
initiatives.
But we can all think of examples
where that's not
true, where those two forces
aren't that important.
So it's the third one that
really does the work.
The idea is that leaders are
almost always chosen.
Leaders of important
organizations, large and
powerful organizations,
are selected through
some sort of a process.
So the ideal example of this is
General Electric, sort of a
classic American corporation.
There are more shares of General
Electric outstanding
than for any other corporation
in the United States.
Been successful for 100 years.
And the way GE chooses its
managers, it doesn't hire
anyone from outside.
They work their way up the
ranks of GE for 20 years.
And at the end of the day,
you've got five finalists, and
GE picks one of those.
So if you think about that
process of constant, repeated
evaluation over decades, what I
say is that , when you think
about those five finalists-- and
this is the social science
theory, in general--
there are two things you should
take away from that.
The first one is this idea that
all five of these people
are probably going to be
really good at the job,
because if they're not, how
did they get there?
If GE was not good at picking
leaders, how could GE have
been successful for 100 years,
if it wasn't able to identify
people who would actually make
pretty good managers?
But I say the second thing you
should believe about those top
five people is that it doesn't
matter which one of them get
chosen, because how different
could they possibly be?
They've all spent two decades
being evaluated by GE.
And they're close enough to what
GE thinks of for what its
ideal CEO would look like
that they've made it
to the final five.
So it probably doesn't matter
this much which one you pick.
So this is what I mean
by leader impact.
It's the counterfactual.
You take the person who did
become the leader, and you
compare him or her to the person
who might have become
the leader.
The most plausible alternatives
and the impact is
the marginal difference between
what did happen and
what could have happened, what
most likely would have
happened if this alternative
person had been chosen.
And this, to me, means
that impact is
high risk, high reward.
If we're defining impact as
someone has an individual
impact when they do something
that almost anyone else in the
same situation would not have
done, what do we know about
those kinds of decisions?
What I'd say is that we know
that they're either great--
you do something that all the
experts tell you is a bad
idea, and it turns out
you were right.
And we look back and say, wow,
that person's a genius.
That's a remarkable
achievement.
But most of the time, if you
do something and all the
experts tell you that's
not a good idea,
well, they're right.
That's what makes you
an expert, right?
So the worst decisions are
equally the ones where a
leader of an organization says,
we're going to do this,
and everybody says, well,
that's a bad idea.
And it was a bad idea,
and it's disastrous.
So leader impact isn't just
a positive thing.
This is the idea that leader
impact can be great,
or it can be awful.
So how do we think through about
when you get a leader
who really does make a
difference, who does have that
kind of impact?
See, it's most organizations,
especially big ones, have a
pool of people who might
someday get to the top.
I call this the candidate
pool.
And you almost think of it like
everybody in the company.
Over time, these people
are evaluated.
They're filtered.
They're exposed to what I call
the leader filtration process.
And this process is evaluating
these people and saying, is
this person what we're
looking for?
If he or she is not, then they
get pushed out of contention
for running the company
or the country.
And if you look at the recent
primaries for the United
States presidential nomination,
this, I think, is
actually a pretty good summary
of what happens.
If you looked at the Republican
primaries, where
they were trying to choose
a nominee, they
weren't picking a winner.
They were picking losers--
you drop out, then you drop
out, then you drop out.
And there's one person left
standing who passes through
all the filters.
So this process determines
who is going to leave the
organization.
And it combines both random
and non-random elements.
So what I mean by that is
non-random elements are things
that tell you what this person
will actually do if you give
them power, how smart they are,
how good a manager they
are, what their beliefs are, are
they risk takers, are they
conservative, all these things
that we really, really care
about when we think about, are
we going to give this person a
position of authority.
But there are also random
elements, things that have
absolutely no impact on what the
person is going to do, but
that still play a big role in
determining whether they're
going to get the job or not.
A classic one of these
is height.
Fortune 500 CEOs are
almost always tall.
They're almost always
over six feet tall,
almost universally so.
No one thinks that height
makes you a
better manager, right?
No one thinks that, gee, only
someone who's over six feet
tall should be the CEO of
a Fortune 500 company.
But somehow, these companies
always end up picking the
people who are six feet tall.
So height is a classical
random factor.
But you can think of any number
of others that have the
same effect, right?
So this process, over
time, homogenizes
the candidate pool.
It makes the people who, as they
survive the filter, look
more and more similar.
But because it's random, there's
a random element, they
don't get identical.
They just get more and more
similar, where people have
different probabilities of
passing through the process
based on the non-random
elements.
The non-random elements
are the ones that
tell you your odds.
But there's a mixture.
So over time, you can think of
the pool as being divided into
two groups.
I call the first
of them modals.
They're people who have a good
chance of being chosen.
They are a close fit for what
the process is actually
looking for, which might be
intelligence, it might be
managerial ability, it
might be height.
Whatever it is, they're
a close fit.
And then there are the people
I call the extremes, the
people who aren't
like the modal.
The random elements are
shuffling them back into the
mix, because they keep
having an effect.
And what I'd say is that the
modals are all similar.
That's what it means
to be at the mode.
The extremes probably have
nothing in common, except for
the fact that they're
not like the mode.
They're different.
That's the key.
They're just different.
So the process over time, you
get relatively fewer extremes.
You go through, and eventually,
you pick a winner.
Could be a mode, could
be at the extreme.
And if you want to know if
someone is going to have a
high impact, what you want to
know is, which one are they?
It's that simple.
You want to know which
one they are.
So how do you know?
I'd say that the way we think
about that is go back to this
idea of filtration.
The more thoroughly someone has
been filtered once they've
won, before they won, the more
thoroughly they were
evaluated, the smaller the
likelihood is that he or she
was actually an extreme.
You're a likely modal if you've
had a long career
inside the organization, you've
been evaluated for a
long time, you're frequently
evaluated, no major failures,
within an old and established
corporation-- that's why I
always pick GE, it's the perfect
example for this--
from a large pool of candidates,
because there's a
lot of people to
choose between.
Unfiltered leaders are just
the mirror image of that.
It's that simple.
They're the flip side, the
people who haven't been
evaluated, who haven't been
inspected, who've somehow come
in from the outside, people whom
you just don't know all
that much about, about what
they're going to do before you
put them in charge.
And then, of course, once you
put them in charge, they're
affected by these same two
ideas, that the power of force
one that constructs them from
the outside and the power of
force two that constructs
them from the inside.
But sometimes, they can still
make a difference.
So that gives me
two predictions
about unfiltered leaders.
The first one is that they
deviate from the norm, and
they do what others
would not do.
So their performance is going
to vary more, do either very
well or very poorly.
And the second one is that
they'll have a high impact,
they'll do things that
are different.
So we can test the first one
statistically and the second
one historically.
That's how we go through
the metrics.
What does the statistical
test look like?
This is a rough test.
But it's designed to be just
indicative, largely because of
the importance of the
historical test.
So what I looked at was
presidents of the United
States, something that's
obviously very relevant now,
in late October in 2012.
Historians have ranked
presidents of the United
States, every president of the
United States, about 13 times
over the last 60 years.
So every four years, not by
coincidence, they go through
this exercise of looking at the
presidents and saying, who
did really well and who
did really poorly?
Now, the striking thing about
these rankings is they've been
done many times by many
different groups of
historians, who've been asked
many different questions about
how should you rank the
presidents, by what criteria,
by what categories, and the end
result is always the same.
The rankings always come out to
be basically the same from
person to person to person.
This, when you think about it,
is not that surprising.
Pretty much everyone agrees
that Abraham Lincoln and
George Washington should
be at the top.
And most people agree that
Franklin Roosevelt should be
at the top.
And just about everyone agrees
that James Buchanan should be
at the bottom.
There's not a lot of debate
about these things.
Once you stretch the time period
out for a long period
and we look back in history,
yeah, Abraham Lincoln saves
the country, he probably
did well.
And by the way, the only major
change in that over the last
60 years is Dwight Eisenhower.
Eisenhower shoots up the
rankings over time.
As we get to know more and
more about what happened
inside the Eisenhower
administration, our view of
that administration changes
completely over time.
So these rankings have been used
by psychologists before
as a way of testing theories
about leadership.
And the idea here is the
prediction is simple.
If you take all those rankings
and average them out--
though you really don't have
to do that, because they're
always basically the same--
the unfiltered leaders should
be at the top and the bottom
of the rankings,
disproportionately.
It's that simple.
So how do we pick whether a
president is filtered or
unfiltered?
What I say is go back to this
idea of evaluation and think
about how you evaluate
someone before
you make them president.
What I've said is that, look,
being sheriff of a small town
doesn't tell you a lot
about what this
person is going to do.
What we want to know is
positions in national
political office, positions
where the political elites,
the people who really know, as
much as anyone can, what it's
like to be president, get to
see you and see, OK, how do
you handle things
under pressure?
What are you like when
the chips are down?
the cameras are off?
So when you're not showing off
for the public, how do you
really act?
How do we really get
to know someone?
You can't know someone
in a job interview.
That's not possible.
You can't know someone through
a reporter's filter, because
you put on a false face.
We all do when we're trying
to impress people.
To get to know someone, you've
got to spend time with them.
And so the idea here is time
in filtering positions,
national prominent positions.
I use eight years in
the United States.
Eight years, to my mind,
just makes sense.
Two presidential terms.
In most states, that's two
terms as a governor.
This feels like a fairly long
span of time to get to
evaluate someone and know what
the real effects of their
decisions are.
In the United States, there are
three things-- because our
political system is, by world
standards, kind of odd--
that come up that don't affect
you in other countries.
The first one is vice
presidents.
In the United States, you can
become vice president.
If a president dies, the
president goes to the top, and
nobody gets a vote.
You don't get to say, well,
that's an awful choice.
So there's no filtering there.
It just happens automatically.
And we can all think of vice
presidents who've been picked
for extraordinarily random
reasons, where no one was
thinking, oh, well, gee that
might be the next president.
That's who we want.
That happens.
There are two exceptions.
Gerald Ford and Harry Truman
were both picked as vice
president in the sure and
certain knowledge that they
would soon be president
of the United States.
But in general, that doesn't
happen very often.
The second thing is, in the
19th century, the United
States had dark horse
candidates, where the
political conventions would
all get together.
And there'd be lots
of candidates,
and they would deadlock.
And someone would end up winning
whom no one thought
should be the nominee, who got
no votes on the first ballot.
So again, I say that's not a
filtered candidate, because
clearly, people aren't looking
at this person, saying, I want
them to be president of the
United States, because nobody
was voting for them until all
the people who they really
wanted were knocked out
of the process.
And the last one comes up less
in the United States, but it's
theoretically important--
this idea of family
advantages.
You come from a rich and
powerful and prominent family.
And the idea here is that, when
you come from that kind
of a background, every
achievement you have leading
up to the time you get to become
president is of less
informational value than those
achievements would be from
someone who doesn't have those
advantages, because it was
easier for you to get those
things than it would be for
someone else.
So it looks like you've done
really impressive things.
But it's harder for us to know
what they tell us about what
you are really like, the real
underlying capabilities that
we care about, because once
you are president, those
family advantages aren't going
to help you out anymore.
All right, so if you look at
all the presidents of the
United States--
and I code all the ones who are
worth looking at, because
William Henry Harrison--
really, what's the point?
He was president for two
weeks before he died.
We don't really care.
So if you look at all of them,
what you see is a remarkable
degree of variance in the amount
of time they spent in
office filtering positions,
from Gerald Ford--
24 years--
all the way to Chester Arthur,
probably the most random of
all American presidents,
who had one year
before he became president.
So there's a big,
big split here.
And if you see, that's
my eight-year cutoff.
So the thing about that cutoff
is it doesn't matter.
If you move the cutoff to six
years, not a single data point
flips from filtered
to unfiltered.
If you move it to nine years,
none of them flip.
So there's just a really nice,
natural break in the data that
tells us that we really are
dealing with two populations
that seem to be pretty
distinct.
So if you look at the chart, the
visual the chart, I would
say, is that this is one of
my happiest moments on the
project, when I put this
together, because the visual
is what you'd think it
would look like.
You get unfiltered presidents
at the top, unfiltered
presidents at the bottom, and
not many in the middle.
So statistically, what are the
odds that you would get that
distribution?
I used the Monte Carlo
simulation to test that.
And what I found out was it's
statistically significant at
the 99.97% level.
Those of you who have social
science training know that in
the social sciences,
you never see--
you don't even see
99% statistical
significance, much less 99.9.
And if you're curious--
I'm guessing, at Google, people
will be curious--
I'm happy to step through more
of the math on that and all
the sort of tests of rigor
and validity that I
did on top of that.
But this is the simple answer
for how we did that test.
All right, so let's take
a look at the history.
The history, I'd say,
that's the fun part.
That's where you really get
into the nitty-gritty of
what's happening here.
So I'm going to take you through
two presidents of the
United States.
The first one is one who's very
famous, who we all think
of as a great person and a great
president, but who, I
argue, as president, actually
had a very low impact--
Thomas Jefferson.
So Thomas Jefferson is about as
thoroughly filtered before
he became president as
it is possible for a
human being to be.
He was a member of the
Continental Congress.
He was America's envoy to France
at a time when that is
the most important diplomatic
position the United States
has, like equivalent to
Secretary of State.
He was then the first
He was Vice President of the
United States to John Adams.
And then he became President
of the United States.
He is an extended evaluation
by other political elites.
He was a man of extraordinary
gifts, John Kennedy famously
quipped in front of a dinner
in honor of American Nobel
Laureates in the 1960s.
He said that this is the
greatest assemblage of talent
ever to be in the White
House since Thomas
Jefferson dined alone.
So very gifted man, but a
very well-evaluated one.
So Thomas Jefferson's elected
president in 1800, in what is
probably the single strangest
and most confusing of all
American presidential
elections.
And this is because of a mistake
the founding fathers
had made in drafting the
Constitution, where presidents
are elected by the electoral
college.
And the way they did it was the
person who got the highest
number of votes came in first,
and the person who got the
second highest number of votes
came in second and became the
vice president.
And they didn't differentiate
between votes for president
and vice president.
So in the election of 1800,
Thomas Jefferson--
his running mate
is Aaron Burr--
Thomas Jefferson ties his
own running mate for the
presidency.
This, to put it mildly,
is odd.
It gets even more complicated,
because Thomas Jefferson--
remember, the person who came
in second in the electoral
college becomes the
vice president--
Thomas Jefferson was the sitting
vice president at the
time, running against his
own president, John
Adams, in the election.
I can only imagine what those
Cabinet meetings were like.
So this became an enormous
political struggle that goes
through dozens and dozens of
rounds of votes in the House
to decide the president.
But at the end of the day,
Jefferson does beat, again,
his own vice presidential
nominee, Aaron Burr, and
becomes President of
the United States.
And he becomes president largely
because everyone
agrees that he's the person who
deserves to be president.
He is the person people thought
they were voting for
when they cast their
ballots, if not
for this fluke mischance.
So I'd say that Jefferson's
the clear most probable
winner, and he is the
clear modal pick.
He is the baseline.
So then, who are the
alternatives?
Who else could have
been President
of the United States?
I'd say there are really
two people.
The first is James Madison.
James Madison was the second
most important Republican at
the time Jefferson was the head
of the Republican Party,
which is now the Democratic
Party.
He was the second most
important Republican.
He was the person Thomas
Jefferson actually had wanted
to run for president.
Jefferson said, Madison,
I don't want to run.
You do it.
Madison said, no, you
have to do it.
You have to run.
And the other alternative is
John Adams, the sitting
President of the United States,
the person who might
have won the election
if things had been
a little bit different.
So if we want to find out what
Jefferson's impact was, we
have to compare him to what
Madison and Adams would have
done in the same situation.
So how do we do that?
So we look at Thomas
Jefferson again.
So Thomas Jefferson is the
fourth ranked president in the
historian surveys.
This makes him a big problem for
my theory, because how do
you have a high impact if you're
so thoroughly filtered?
How are you the top
ranked person
without having an impact?
So Jefferson is the fourth
ranked president for a really
simple reason-- the Louisiana
Purchase.
If you double the size of your
country peacefully at trivial
cost, historians
say, good job.
Well done.
This is a great thing.
So the question is, what did
Jefferson have to do with the
Louisiana Purchase?
Is he responsible for
the purchase?
Or if somebody else had
been there, would
it still have happened?
So this is the chronology.
Jefferson sends somebody to
Paris to negotiate a purchase
of land from France, but not
the purchase of Louisiana.
This person is sent to negotiate
just the purchase of
the city of New Orleans.
As far as we can tell, not a
single person in the United
States ever discussed the
possibility of buying the
entire territory of Louisiana.
This person, before he arrives
in Paris, before he even shows
up, Napoleon's foreign minister
comes to the American
ambassador who is resident at
the time and says, how would
you guys like to buy
all of Louisiana?
Unsurprisingly, the American
ambassador says, well, sure,
that sounds like a great idea.
And so my argument appears
pretty simple.
How can you say Jefferson was
responsible for it if his guy
hadn't even shown up yet?
So then it comes back.
The news of the purchase
arrives in Boston.
And this is not incredibly
controversial.
When the news arrived in Boston
of the possibility of
the purchase, the city set off
a fireworks celebration in
order to say, what an incredible
opportunity for the
United States.
It goes to a vote to
ratify the treaty.
And the biggest single obstacle
of the successful
ratification of the treaty is
Thomas Jefferson, because
Jefferson believed that the
Federal government did not
have the power to get territory,
to expand territory
of the United States, and
so wanted to pass a
constitutional amendment.
Napoleon, who, remember, had
overthrown the government of
France, was not exactly
sympathetic to constitutional
arguments and basically said,
look, either stop talking
about this, or I'm going to
pull out of the treaty.
And so Madison went
to Jefferson and
said, stop doing this.
This is too important.
You need to stop causing
problems.
And the treaty passes,
and the United
States purchases Louisiana.
So we know that Madison would
have done the same thing,
because Madison is the guy who
forced Jefferson to do what he
did to cause the treaty
successfully.
If you look at John Adams,
well, John Adams
was no longer president.
But he wrote in private letters
that he supported the
purchase and would
have done it.
And we know that his son, John
Quincy Adams, who was a
senator at the time, crossed
party lines to vote in favor
of Jefferson's purchase on
multiple occasions, something
that's basically inconceivable
he would have done if his
father disapproved of the
purchase in the first place.
So my argument here isn't that
Jefferson was a bad president.
He clearly was a very
good president.
This level of diplomatic skill
and the flexibility in the
negotiations with Congress to
get this through was a huge
asset for the country.
But vice president, Secretary
of State, governor of
Virginia, ambassador
to France--
you should expect this guy
to be a good president.
They spent a long time
evaluating him.
How could he not be a
good president after
such a period of time?
So the argument here
isn't that he
wasn't a good president.
It's that he had a low impact,
because James Madison was also
going to be a pretty
good president.
James Madison succeeded
Jefferson as president and
would have done the
same thing.
So if that's low impact, what
does high impact look like?
Let's take a look at
Abraham Lincoln.
I personally think Abraham
Lincoln might be the most
fascinating person
who's ever lived.
So think about how Abraham
Lincoln becomes President of
the United States.
There's a big movie about him
coming out soon, so people
might be more familiar
with this soon.
But national elites knew
amazingly little about Abraham
Lincoln before he became
president.
He has one term in the House.
He's run for the Senate twice,
and he's lost both times.
Many of you, I'm sure, remember
Barack Obama's
incredible speech at the
Democratic National Convention
in 2004, the one that sort
of instantly made
him a national celebrity.
So in 2004, he was running
for the Senate.
He wins that election.
And in 2008, four years later,
he runs for the presidency.
And he's got four years in
the Senate as a platform.
Abraham Lincoln similarly has
an incredible dynamic speech
that helps to make him
a national figure.
But Lincoln lost his
Senate race.
So the way to think about just
how obscure Abraham Lincoln
was, is he's Barack Obama in
2008 if Obama had lost the
2004 Senate race to be senator
from Illinois.
And he's running
for president.
So his big rival there is
Stephen Douglas, who is the
Republican senator from Illinois
and is the Democratic
Senator and would be the
Democratic nominee for
president in 1860.
He's the man who beat Lincoln.
And he's going to be the
Democratic nominee.
So he's the guy the Republicans
know they have to
beat straight-up in the election
if they want to win
the presidency.
So Lincoln's nomination is
incredibly unlikely.
He's generally dismissed as
a fringe candidate for the
nomination.
And a bunch of fluke
circumstances, basically, are
what enable him to win.
The first is a raid by a
man named John Brown.
That's his picture there, in
Harper's Ferry in Virginia.
The raid was designed to set
off a slave insurrection in
the southern states.
The raid failed miserably,
was a complete failure.
But it terrified moderates,
people who weren't all that
fired up about slavery, in the
North and made them much, much
less likely to vote for anyone
who's perceived as an
anti-slavery radical.
Lincoln's national record was
so short that he was able to
convincingly portray himself
as the most moderate-- that
is, the least anti-slavery--
Republican.
The second element is the
location of the convention.
The convention is put in
Illinois, in Chicago.
Lincoln is from Illinois.
So why is the convention
in Illinois?
And the answer is the Republican
National Committee
voted to put it there.
The vote was carried by one
vote over Missouri.
And the argument that won the
day for Illinois was that
there were no significant
Republicans from Illinois, so
it would be neutral territory
where none of the contenders
would have a home
field advantage.
But of course, one
of them does.
And Lincoln's team takes
advantage of that in, let's
say, a fashion we don't normally
associate with
Abraham Lincoln.
So it's in Chicago.
Lincoln's team goes out, and
they recruit people from all
across the state.
And the way they recruit them
is they get the people with
the loudest voices.
And then they print fake
tickets and stack the
convention the audience
with these people.
So every time Lincoln's name is
mentioned on the floor of
the convention, these guys are
all taught to start whooping
and hollering and screaming and
shouting so loudly that
the windows of the building
actually start to shake.
It's an enormous psychological
battle.
And then Lincoln's campaign
manager is a
guy named David Davis.
Now, Davis is such a novice that
he has never even visited
a convention before.
So the guy who really should
have been the presidential
nominee is this man, William
Henry Seward, two-term
governor, two-term senator,
founding father of the
Republican Party, man of
international reputation,
among the foremost anti-slavery
voices in the country.
If you're going to pick a person
to lead the country
through its moment of greatest
crisis, which 1860 undoubtedly
was, William Henry Seward
is the man you pick.
Seward's campaign manager
is a man gloriously
named Thurlow Weed.
Thurlow Weed is the finest
political operative of his
generation.
Think of him as the
Karl Rove of 19th
century American politics.
So you've got the best political
operative of his
generation versus a guy who's
never even shown up at a
convention.
This should not be
an even match.
But what this guy knows is,
because he has the home field
advantage, he knows that the
convention will be chaos, and
he goes to the people in
charge of the seating
arrangements.
And he has New York, Seward's
delegation, with Weed in it
seated between two other
delegations that are
pro-Seward.
And by doing that, he knows
that when the negotiations
have to take place, [? those ?]
[? two ?]
[? then ?] are going to flip
states and choose a final
winner, Weed will be physically
unable to the work
his way across the convention
floor to talk to other people.
So if you ever think that
everything in American
politics is calm and rational,
just remember that the seating
arrangements of the convention
floor in 1860 helped to decide
who would become President
of the United States.
The final thing were favorite
son candidates.
That's candidates who have
support from a single state
and are not plausible contenders
for the national
election, but who have enough
votes to stop Seward from
winning on the first ballot.
So you have a ballot.
Seward's way in the lead,
but there's no winner.
And then Lincoln's campaign
manager goes to Simon Cameron,
the governor of Pennsylvania,
who controls the Pennsylvania
delegates, says, if you flip to
Lincoln, Lincoln will get
enough momentum that he'll
overtake Seward, and he'll win
the election.
And Simon Cameron is a man so
famously corrupt that, a few
years later, when he was in
Lincoln's Cabinet, he was
accused of being willing
to steal anything
but a red-hot stove.
When the person who accused him
of that, Lincoln forced
him to apologize, he said,
I'm sorry, you would
also steal the stove.
So Cameron says, what
can you give me?
And Lincoln telegrams his
campaign team, "Make no deals
that will bind me." Says, "Make
no deals." Lincoln's
campaign manager says,
Lincoln's not here.
And he says to Cameron, if you
agree to support Lincoln,
we'll put you in the Cabinet.
Cameron does.
Lincoln becomes the nominee, and
then he becomes President
of the United States.
And Lincoln sticks
to the deal.
He makes Cameron Secretary
of War.
So I say that there are
lots of ways you
can tell this story.
And it's a fascinating
and a fun story.
Actually, I'm only skimming
the surface.
The book will tell you a lot
more of the details.
And they are every bit as crazy
as the ones I've talked
about here.
But this is not a story about
picking the person most likely
to win the Civil War
for the North.
This is a story with just random
element after random
element adding up.
So then, what's the impact?
I said, we don't want to cause
a chain of events.
In 1864, we don't know what the
world would have looked
like if Abraham Lincoln had
not been president.
So let's look at the first
decision he makes as president.
The very first decision is at
the crisis over Fort Sumter.
Sumter is a fort in
Charleston Harbor.
It's besieged by South
Carolina militia.
It is basically one of the only
two Federal possessions
in the seceded states.
Seward's policy is
to give it up.
He says, let's give the fort to
the South, and we'll break
what he calls the secessionist
fever.
He says, they're not serious.
They're only bluffing.
They don't really want
to leave the country.
And if that's not true, then
what we should do is start a
war with Spain and France.
And if we do that, then in the
war, everybody will rally to
the flag, and the South
will come back in.
Lincoln doesn't think so.
So Lincoln doesn't make a
position [INAUDIBLE], but it's
clear that he's not going
to do what Seward wants.
And so Seward tries to seize
control of the government.
Remember, Seward is the guy
with the international
reputation.
Lincoln is the hick from the
small town in Illinois.
That's the way Seward
thinks of it.
No one knows who this guy is.
And so Steward sends Lincoln
what is probably the most
remarkable document
ever received
by an American president.
So you guys have
all seen memos.
I'm not going to read the
whole thing to you.
But I want one sentence
to get emphasized--
"Either the president must do it
himself or devolve it upon
some member of the Cabinet.
It is not my especial province,
but I neither or
seek to evade nor assume
responsibility."
You've all read memos.
This message is really clear.
He's telling Lincoln, make
me the shadow president.
Let me make all the decisions.
And you just sort
of sit in front.
So he's completely misread
his man, of course.
But think about this.
How could he have read
Lincoln successfully?
He has no data.
One term in Congress.
And so what Lincoln says to
him is, "We can do many
things, but whatever must be
done, I must do it." But
instead of causing a feud with
his Secretary of State, what
Lincoln does is his skills with
management of people are
so extraordinary that a few
months later, Seward tells his
wife, "I am enormously glad that
President Lincoln is here
to guide the country
in this crisis.
Of all of the men in the
country, he is the best of
us," the only person
who could do this.
So then Lincoln does
his master stroke.
Some people in the Cabinet
wanted to give up the fort and
let the South go peacefully.
Some people had wanted
to fight right away.
And the country, the North,
is not unified at all.
Maybe a third of people in
the North actually want
to fight this war.
Most of the rest are sort of,
it's just not worth it.
Think about how bad this
war could get.
It's not worth it.
Let it go in peace.
And what Lincoln does
is he sends food.
And he sends it publicly,
instead of trying to sneak it
past the guards.
And by doing that, he puts the
decision in the hands of the
South Carolina radicals as to
whether they're going to stop
the food from getting
to the fort.
And they choose to do it.
They just fire first.
And by firing first, they
unify the country behind
Lincoln in the war effort.
Think about what the United
States was like on September
11 or what it must have been
like on December 7, 1941.
When somebody shoots at your
flag, partisan political
differences vanish for
a little while.
And so Lincoln suddenly
has a unified North to
prosecute the war.
Without that, it's impossible
to imagine how he could have
fought it successfully.
So I'd say that Lincoln's impact
here is the Civil War
either doesn't happen or is lost
if Abraham Lincoln is not
President of the
United States.
It's hard to imagine, again,
more impact than
that from one person.
All right, so if that's
politics, how about in
business and science?
Let me give you one example
of each, quickly.
This is Albert J. Dunlap,
my pick for worst
CEO in human history.
He built a record of moving from
company to company as a
turnaround artist, where
he would slash costs.
He eventually ends up at Scott
Paper, where he slashes cost,
raises profits, and sells the
company to Kimberly Clark for
three times what it was
worth when he was
initially hired as CEO.
Seems like an incredible
success story, right?
So the problem is--
well, we'll see.
So Dunlap is then hired to
become the CEO of Sunbeam.
Sunbeam's just a consumer
products company, pretty
profitable, nothing special.
They think it needs someone
to really improve things.
And the way he's hired is a
member of Sunbeam's board
reads a magazine profile of
Dunlap and says, this might be
our guy, has a four-hour
meeting with him.
Dunlap then meets with
representatives of the two
biggest investors in Sunbeam--
not the investors, just
their representatives.
And he's hired with carte
blanche to do anything that he
wants at Sunbeam before most
members of the board of
directors even know he's
under contention.
He's in their consideration
to be CEO.
I would say this is probably not
how you want to evaluate a
CEO before you hire
him or her.
And the reason is there are a
few things that the board
didn't know that they probably
should have.
Divisions Dunlap had run
historically did poorly right
after he left.
He had been fired after seven
weeks for insubordination from
one of his jobs.
He'd been fired as president
of Nitec for his abusive
management style.
They actually sued him for it.
But the suit collapsed, because
Dunlap had also
engaged in massive
accounting fraud.
And the accounting fraud was
so pervasive that it caused
the company to go into
bankruptcy, which made them
stop the lawsuit.
And the way Dunlap was able to
continue his career and get
hired by places like
Kimberly Clark and
eventually Scott is simple.
He didn't list these companies
on his resume.
These sort of incidents were
discovered by "The New York
Times" in an investigation a
couple of years after he was
fired from Sunbeam.
When Kimberly Clark had bought
Scott, what they'd basically
been was the greater fool.
They'd spent three times as much
to buy this company, but
when they bought it, they
discovered that to make it
worth anything at all, they
would have to undo everything
Al Dunlap had done as CEO
of Kimberly Clark.
Oh, by the way, this is how
Dunlap's management style--
I hope Google doesn't
work like this--
Dunlap ordered the head of HR
to his office, threw a chair
at him, swore at him constantly,
and then threw him
back out of the office without
actually giving him an
opportunity to say a word.
And he did all of this in
front of the person's
subordinates.
If that ever happens to
you, it's a good sign
to leave the company.
So that's how Dunlap likes
to run a company.
And so it's a disaster.
His usual trick is he gets
hired, then he arranges an
acquisition.
But that doesn't work here,
because he's such a celebrity
that when he gets hired, the
stock price spikes up.
And suddenly, Sunbeam
is too expensive for
anyone to buy it.
So he tries to arrange
a merger on his
own with other companies.
And at the same time, he's using
really questionable,
really fraudulent accounting
practices to
goose Sunbeam's numbers.
And in the due diligence
investigation that people do
through the M&A, everything
comes out.
Everything falls apart.
Sunbeam's shares start
to plunge.
The board questions Dunlap as to
what on Earth is going on.
Dunlap's response is that
Sunbeam's largest shareholder
is involved in a conspiracy
to drive down the price of
Sunbeam's stock.
The board is understandably
baffled as to why Sunbeam's
largest shareholder would be
trying to decrease the value
of his holdings.
And he's fired.
Dunlap essentially resigns
in disgrace.
And Sunbeam files for
bankruptcy in 2001,
essentially ceases
to exist as an
independently operating company.
So let's say that Dunlap did
the exact same things at
Sunbeam that he did at Kimberly
Clark, that he, in
fact, had done many
times in his past.
But he wasn't discovered.
So the thing here is this is the
classic case of the worst
possible scenario when you hire
an unfiltered leader.
Anyone at his previous
organizations could have told
them that this is the worst
possible person to hire.
Anyone could have
told them that.
But the sort of information you
need to know what someone
is like, that they like to
throw chairs at their
subordinates, that doesn't
filter across organizational
boundaries very well.
That's gossip.
It's the gossip you trade in
the halls, which can be
enormously valuable,
but doesn't go
from place to place.
So here you have this case
where-- this is, by the way,
the title of a book about Al
Dunlap, which was my favorite
business book cover
of all time--
"Chainsaw Al." And maybe all you
really need to know about
Al Dunlap's personality is
that "Chainsaw Al" is the
nickname he gave himself.
But how about science?
So what I'd say is that science
is actually the most
difficult case for personal
impact, because science is
about discovering a natural
world that exists independent
of our own observations.
It's just out there.
So is it possible for a
scientist to have this kind of
huge impact?
Let me give you an example
of one who I think did.
So what does filtration look
like for a scientist?
My argument is that what
it really looks
like is peer review.
We are all familiar with the
peer review process.
And this, to my mind, sounds
a lot like filtration.
It's particularly peer review
for grant applications,
because grant applications
are forward-looking.
So if you submit a grant
application, other scientists
read it, and they say, well,
this is good experiment, this
is a bad experiment.
So here's the problem.
A revolutionary experiment is
one that tells you that what
you know about the
world isn't so.
It tells you that
your long-held
theories are not correct.
So the people who are doing
peer review believe these
long-held theories.
They're going to get 1,000
different proposals for ideas
that disprove long-held
theories.
And at least 999 of those
proposals are wrong.
They will fail.
One of them might succeed.
But it looks just as unlikely as
the other 999, doesn't it?
So the odds of that sort of
revolutionary experiment being
funded tend to drop the more
thoroughly you review
experiments.
So Judah Folkman is a surgeon.
He's the first Ohio State
graduate to go to Harvard
Medical School, which
he did at 20.
Between his second and third
years of medical school, he
took a year off to do research,
which many medical
students do.
In his case, the way he spent
that year was by inventing the
implantable pacemaker.
And in fact, 3M's first ever
commercially released
pacemaker was based on Judah
Folkman's design.
So this is a pretty remarkable
man, to do that at 22.
He's drafted into the Navy.
And while he's in the Navy, he
does research on blood, to
create an artificial
blood substitute.
And to do that, you worked with
cancers, with tumors.
And what he discovers about
tumors is that unless they
have a blood supply, they
stop growing very fast.
So Folkman has an idea,
a lightning
bolt, you might think.
He thinks, maybe tumors aren't
dangerous unless they emit
some sort of a chemical that
causes capillaries to grow
into the tumor and feed it
and allow it to grow.
But he doesn't know what
the chemical is.
And the common view in the
cancer research community at
the time is, nothing
interesting
happens with blood vessels.
They're just dumb tubes.
That's the line people use.
So when he suggests this, that
we should do experiments on
this, nobody buys it.
He doesn't have one day of
formal training as a cancer
researcher.
He's a surgeon.
Folkman's idea is this-- he
calls it angiogenesis.
He says that this is the term
you use for this ability to
generate capillaries that
grow into the tumor.
But he can't identify
the factor.
His ideas gain no traction.
Proposals and grants
are rejected.
Only two papers published,
both in minor journals.
Eventually, the publicity gets
so bad that when he speaks at
a cancer research conference,
150 people get up and walk out
in protest, because
the conference is
wasting their time.
And an investigation of his
work, an independent
investigation launched by
Children's Hospital, where he
is the chief of surgery,
concludes that his research is
"of no value." That's the
quote-- "of no value."
And so the hospital tells
Folkman, you have to either
resign as chief of surgery or
give up cancer research.
You have to do one of the
two, because you're
embarrassing us so much.
Folkman resigns as
chief of surgery.
This is the marginalia in
one of Folkman's grant
applications, where he says,
this is the limit.
We do not want Folkman
to build an empire.
So the way he does his research
is he negotiates the
first ever corporate partnership
for biomedical
research between a corporation
and university.
This is a multi-billion-dollar
industry.
Almost every major university
does it.
Folkman invented that with
Monsanto at Harvard.
In 1979, PNAS publishes a paper
proving that his idea
about the factor is correct--
there is a factor.
In 1980, he proves that
angiogenesis can be inhibited,
that you can stop capillaries
from growing.
In 1989, the factor is
identified by a different
research team after 24
years of searching.
In 1998, the first patient is
successfully treated using an
angiogenesis inhibitor.
Folkman dies in 2008.
And when he dies, 1.2 million
people are being treated by
drugs based on his idea.
So the argument here isn't that
angiogenesis would never
have been discovered
without Folkman.
I think it certainly
would have.
But the way I tell the story
is I don't see any way for
angiogenesis to be discovered
nearly as quickly as it was
without Folkman, because he was
alone on this issue, not
for a month or two,
but for decades.
All right, so a few quick
applications.
The idea here is when you're
choosing leaders, picking an
unfiltered leader is a gamble.
Sometimes, they're going
to be a genius.
Sometimes, they're going to
be a disastrous failure.
And there are many, many
more ways to fail than
there are to succeed.
That's part of life.
So the odds are they're probably
going to fail.
So if you need to innovate,
you might want one.
If you're desperate, if your
company is about to go
bankrupt, well, there's no
outcome worse than bankruptcy.
So you might want one, because
maybe he or she is the only
person who can save you.
If you're in an environment
of limited losses
and unlimited gains.
So if you're a venture
capitalist and you're
investing, the most you can
lose is the amount of your
investment.
But your gain is you might
invest in Google.
So you'd probably be much more
willing to take gambles than
you should be in a different
environment.
You want to avoid false signals,
things like family
wealth, that make someone seem
like they're familiar and
highly evaluated, even
when they aren't.
You want to match people
with situation.
Another key idea here is the
idea there's no such thing as
a best leader.
A lot of these people have
preferences that take them to
success in one environment and
would have taken them to
failure in another one.
The idea here is it's not the
best leader you want; it's the
right leader, the person who
matches this environment and
this situation.
So if you want to be a better
leader yourself, it
says, know your type.
Know yourself.
Understand whether you are
filtered or unfiltered,
because filtered and unfiltered
leaders succeed and
fail for dramatically
different reasons.
Filtered leaders fail when the
external environment changes
and their old ways of doing
things don't work.
And so they need access to those
unfiltered insights.
Unfiltered leaders fail because
they don't know the
organization they're running.
They don't understand
how it works.
They don't have the insider's
knowledge that you really need
to get an organization to
operate successfully.
The final thing here is, in the
book, I talk about a bunch
of different leaders, some of
whom, I say, would've been
disastrous under any
circumstances, and some of
whom were enormously successful,
but in a different
set of circumstances would
have been disastrous.
They just had preferences that
worked really well, that
aligned with that situation.
And in a different circumstance,
their bias would
have failed.
But are there people who are
just genuinely great, who seem
to be able to succeed in any
circumstance where a human
being, it's possible for
them to find success?
I say there are a few.
The two I talk about most often
are Lincoln and Folkman,
I think, are the two who really
do seem to have that.
And what makes them unique, I
would say, goes back to this
idea of, where do these
people succeed, and
where do they fail?
Unfiltered leaders are
able to do what other
people would not do.
Everyone tells them,
this is a bad idea.
And they do it anyway.
So that's incredible levels
of self-confidence.
Think about just how much
self-confidence you have to
be, when the stakes are this
high, to keep going forward.
But at the same time, somehow,
when all these people around
them say, well, this is a bad
idea, they're able to listen
and say, well, maybe it really
is a bad idea, and avoid the
kind of catastrophic mistakes
that could otherwise have
destroyed them.
So this is the paradoxical
combination of supreme
self-confidence and supreme
intellectual humility, the
ability to acknowledge that
you might be wrong.
Abraham Lincoln, I think,
embodies this
more than anyone else.
His second inaugural is, in my
opinion, the greatest speech
any American has ever given.
Every bit of it is
worth studying.
But let me give you one
clause in particular.
"With firmness in the right,
as God gives us to see the
right."
So the Civil War is awful
beyond words.
Tens of thousands of people
die It goes on for years.
It's impossible, in a modern
context, to imagine just how
horrendous the carnage was.
And Lincoln didn't
have to do that.
He chose to do it.
That's firmness in the right.
But he's also the person who's
able to say, I might be wrong,
and change course when
it seems he is wrong.
And so the second half of that
clause is just as important--
"as God gives us to see it."
Being the person is able to be
both of those, both supremely
self-confident and supremely
humble, is, to my mind, the
hallmark of the people who
were great, not just lucky.
Thanks very much.